pour le personnel soignant qui refusent
de se faire vacciner il ya des
conséquences très lourdes depuis hier et
vous êtes une des premières
malheureusement en faire l'expérience et
une suspension vous étiez vous
travaillez pour le centre médico
psychologique du vigan dans le gard et
donc vous êtes suspendu depuis hier mais
avant d'entrer dans les raisons je
voudrais savoir parce que on entend
suspens sur comment ça se passe on
reçoit un courrier directement on à un
entretien préalable comment ça se passe
on a notre cadre qu'il ya un lundi matin
avec une lettre de suspension
je n'ai reçu aucun entretien avec la drh
avec la direction je n'ai pas rencontré
de médecine du travail
on m'a demandé si j'étais vaccinés oui
ou non et on m'a donné une lettre en
disant tu viendras pu travailler à
partir du 15 voilà alors la suspension
c'est également la suspension du salaire
effectivement c'est bien spécifié plus
de salaires plus de droits sociaux ce
qui était marqué sur ma lettre de
suspension
et donc pour vous ça des conséquences
j'imagine
que sérieuse j'ai une petite fille de 10
mois à la maison effectivement ça a des
conséquences plutôt sérieuse pour moi
est ce que cette pression que vous
subissez suspension de salaire
suspension des droits sociaux votre
situation particulière avec un enfant en
bas âge ça vous fait réfléchir quand est
ce que vous pensez recourir à la
vaccination bientôt
donc j'avais des raisons très sérieuse
de la refuser je la refuse d'avoir j'ai
été cuites positive début avril
donc j'ai un passé à une terre qui me
permet d'être un hôpital en tant que
patiente et non en tant que soignante
j'ai des raisons personnelles de la
refuser évidemment je veux prendre du
temps
zeljko vide et lucas vie des raisons
personnelles on veut pas être intrusif
mais c'est d'ordre c'est avec al
psychologique ou non c'est que bon c'est
une belle en balance bénéfice risque
nathan magie le coc vide je m'en suis
très bien sorti sans séquelles et je ne
suis pas contre la vaccination attention
c'est pour ça que je précise que c'est
une balance personnel j'estime que mon
corps c'est la seule chose qui
m'appartiennent vraiment et totalement
et là je ne suis pas prête je ne dis pas
que je serai pas plus tard je dis pas
j'ai dit que pour l'instant je ne suis
pas prête il me faut du temps il faut
certaines études soit faite il me faut
ce recul qui est nécessaire pour moi
actuellement c'est nécessaire et que la
balance bénéfices risques personnels là
ne tend pas vers la vaccination mais
dont vous risques personnels dans la
balance vous devez ajouter maintenant
votre situation financière votre petite
fille s'est pas seulement les risques et
bénéfices du vaccin sur le plan
sanitaire il ya aussi votre votre vie
qui est en quête en jeu celle de votre
petite fille ça ne suffit pas faire
pencher la balance pas pour l'instant en
tout cas des solutions voilà je manque
pas d'en vue de faire des choses j'ai
pas peur de travail physique et
voilà un jour à la fois pour l'instant
pour moi en tout cas donc vous envisagez
plutôt une reconversion que qu'un
changement de situation à l'hôpital il
faut que je digère tout ça il faut que
je dise heures il faut que je prenne du
temps et une reconversion une démission
je ne peux pas vous répondre à l'heure
actuelle je reviendrai vers vous tout à
l'heure mais julien borowczyk votre
votre profil nous intéresse parce que
vous êtes à la fois médecin généraliste
et député de la 6e circonscription de la
loire de la loire oui et président élu
sinon on enterre sur la gestion de la
crise qu'ovide 19 et jeudi que votre
profil nous intéresse parce qu'on a
l'impression que ce débat est au moins
autant politique que sanitaire mais
quand vous entendez ce témoignage de
quelqu'un bonnefoy qui n'est pas dans le
militantisme qui n'est pas dans la
revendication qui dit simplement pour
mon cas personnel je ne l'acceptent pas
qu'est ce que vous pouvez trouver comme
argument pour la convaincre députés la
majorité des budgets bien se décider
mais oui non vous avez déjà posé la
question sera pourquoi vous souhaitiez
pas vous faire vacciner parce que c'est
la première question qui vient à se
poser moi si vous voulez en tout en
toute franchise ce qui m'interpelle
c'est surtout que je me dis je vais être
peut-être un petit peu direct mais c'est
quelque part pour moi un désaveu du
métier dans lequel vous êtes c'est à
dire que en tant que médecin il me
semble que le vaccin fait partie de
l'armada de la thérapeutique moderne
donc quelque part être contre un vaccin
c'est à mes yeux refuser ce qu'est la
médecine moderne c'est avec ça ce que
fait précise bien c'est avec cela c'est
pour ça que c'est intéressant qu'on
puisse débat de savoir la question c'est
pourquoi ce vaccin alors à ce moment-là
c'est de votre faute
ça fait deux ans toujours de votre faute
donc c'est moi je suis rodé
vous parlez des vaccins qui sont déjà
obligatoires et que j'ai accepté
consciemment de faire oui en faisant
cette profession j'ai accepté pour me
protéger on n'est pas dans la même
dimension là actuellement pour me
protéger moi et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
me choque un peu tant que ça d'ailleurs
parce que la question si vous voulez ici
c'est pas un scoop mais la question
c'est de vous protéger bien évidemment
mais aussi de protéger les autres c'est
toute la problématique de la vaccination
elle savoir que la le le coc vide est
devenue une maladie nosocomiale non
négligeable 27000 cas de contamination à
l'hôpital c'est à dire que moi ce que je
ne peux pas entendre c'est qu'on rentre
pour une entorse de cheville à l'hôpital
en ressort avec un co lead qu'on soit
contaminée par quelqu'un c'est leur
demander de travailler en étant positif
un moment oui oui
c'est complètement différent parce que
ils travaillaient dans des dents des
services ovi de plus
de venir travailler j'ai eu le coach on
m'a demandé si j'avais des symptômes ou
pas si je n'avais pas de symptômes on
m'a dit tu vas au travail oui quand vous
travaillez
sur un service providence dans tous les
esprits disco vide plus qu avez-vous
déjà vu le comité a demandé de venir
travailler si je n'avais pas de
symptômes tous les services n'étaient
pas d'être si vous voulez la question la
question c'est vraiment une fois de plus
le rapport bénéfice risque c'est à quel
moment on était dans une période on
avait énormément d'hospitalisation de
surcroît moi quand j'entends justement
cette polémique sur le manque de
matériel etc moi je suis quand même
assez surpris de voir des gens qui nous
disent vous nous avez envoyées il n'y
avait pas de masque maintenant qu'on a
bien mieux que le mas et avec ça on
refuse ok ça c'est paradoxal de
vous je peux vous poser une question
actuellement dans mon service au cmp
nous sommes quatre infirmières trois qui
sont non vaccinés oui une kg et vaccinés
oui celle qui actuellement font des
tests et bien travaillé avec un test
négatif c'est celle qui ne sont pas
vaccinés oui et celle qui a eu récemment
le coc vide et qui était positif c'est
celle qui est vaccinée non mais
[Applaudissements]
on
peut re discuter de ça le problème c'est
que s'ils voulaient étaient probablement
positif pas de souci le seul truc c'est
quand vous êtes vacciné vous avez
beaucoup moins de risques de contaminer
c'est ça la problématique est la thèse
de moins de 72 heures nous avons bien
dit m j'ai je sais que j'ai un travail
est négatif c'est la première non
admises et profond mais pourquoi elle
tombe bien cette crise parce que email
imagine-t-on un militaire qui sur le
champ de bataille recul parce que il est
contre la mission qu'on lui donne
imaginez un policier on lui dit d'aller
arrêter une personne ou alors il va
intervenir et ils diraient non pas en
vérité pas alors je suis allé vers mais
ils diraient non je ne vais pas au bout
de ma mission parce que ce n'est pas
conforme à ce que ce dont j'ai envie il
ya des métiers et dont le métier de
soigner c'est un des plus beaux métiers
du monde qui nécessite un engagement
très fort et ça fait partie de cette
engage donc déjà remettre en cause les
autorités de santé qui ont autorisé
l'accès alors qu'on et soignants cela
met quand même si vous voulez un certain
doute sur les personnes qui le refusent
moi j'aurais peur d'être soignées par
quelqu'un qui n'a pas confiance aux
autorités de santé ensuite reculer et de
dire qu'on fait les choses pour soi même
quand on est dans un métier de santé ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qui me semble
la compréhensive et enfin c'est pas la
peine de faire comme si lundi on
découvrait des choses mais surtout de
fruits juillet ça a été annoncé ça veut
dire que choix à chacun depuis juillet
on peut s'organiser quand on a des
enfants on peut pas dire qu'on n'a été
prévenue est mis de côté en trois jours
tout ça c'est du mensonge a préconisé
pour le moment mais toujours trouvé
l'excusé si vous voulez j'entends les
messages généraux toulon trouve l excuse
de oui mais intel étaient vaccinés a été
contaminé la réalité c'est quand rien
n'est fait sur dix qui sont en rien ne
sont pas vaccinés ça c'est la réalité et
comme par hasard ce vaccin qui soit
disant ne sera rien puisque il ne met
pas fin il est évident que dicte pas
d'épidémie depuis que les gens sont
vaccinés vous avez vu les chiffres
aujourd'hui est bon on peut vivre